[Music]
if you use prometheus to monitor your
services and infrastructure you probably
have a set of configurations you've
developed over months or years that
serve you really well but managing and
maintaining them can be a challenge
today i'm going to show you how to
migrate your existing prometheus setup
including your application monitoring
configurations to manage collection and
remove the need to manage any part of
prometheus at scale my name is yuri and
i'm an sre at google cloud welcome back
to engineering for reliability
the prometheus operator is a common way
to manage prometheus deployments in
production the operator uses custom
resources to manage the prometheus
server itself you then define service
monitor resources to configure how
specific services are monitored
you can certainly use prometheus
operator with google cloud's managed
service for prometheus but migrating to
manage collection means you won't have
to manage any prometheus infrastructure
at all let's have a look at how to
migrate an existing prometheus
configuration managed by the operator to
manage collection
let's start by reviewing our existing
configuration
we have a prometheus operator and the
prometheus server running in the
monitoring namespace
our app is running in the default
namespace we can confirm that it's
exposing prometheus metrics on the slash
metrics endpoint by using port
forwarding
and there we are
[Music]
we instruct the prometheus operator to
monitor our app by using a service
monitor resource
here's our configuration
[Music]
and here it is deployed on the server
we can use port forwarding to confirm
that prometheus has our app as a target
and that it is ingesting our apps
metrics
[Music]
at this point we're ready to migrate to
manage collection
[Music]
we're going to enable manage collection
in the cloud console here you can also
do this with the gcloud command if
you're not running on gke you can also
use cube ctl
once that's done we need to instruct
prometheus to monitor our app to do this
we'll use a pod monitoring configuration
manage collection uses pod monitoring
resources instead of service monitors to
guarantee that each collector only
scrapes targets on the node it's running
on this guarantees scalability by
minimizing intra-cluster traffic
the configuration itself is similar to
the service monitor resource but you may
need to change some fields we'll link to
the documentation in the episode notes
so you can be sure to get this right
let's apply this configuration
[Music]
at this point we can confirm that our
application metrics are being ingested
by querying them using promql
and in metrics explorer
[Music]
and that's how you can migrate an
existing prometheus configuration to
google's managed prometheus collection
thanks so much for watching today we'll
learn how to migrate an existing
prometheus operator deployment to
google's managed prometheus collection
and how to use a pod monitoring resource
to ensure that your service is monitored
i hope this helps you keep your services
reliable and users happy if you have any
other reliability or observability topic
you'd like me to cover please comment
below
don't forget to like and subscribe to
never miss out on more engineering for
reliability with google cloud see you
soon
[Music]
you